hi everyone sal khan here and i just
wanted to
tell y'all that we've reached kind of
several really cool milestones at khan
lab school which you can learn more
about it
connlabschool.org or kls.org
a lot of folks are surprised to hear
that i started a physical school back in
2014 when i'm so associated with online
learning but i've never viewed online as
somehow a replacement for an in-person
experience the dream has always been
that online can unlock the physical
experience it can allow students to
learn at a pace that is appropriate for
them it could allow for mastery-based
learning where if you get an eighty
percent on something you don't just get
a c on your forehead and your permanent
transcript and then you're expected to
learn the next concept that builds on
that 20 gap instead you're expected to
master the concept so you always have a
strong foundation
that we can unlock a situation where
when human beings get to a classroom
together both the students and the
teachers they're able to interact with
each other they're able to collaborate
with each other they're able to have
socratic dialogues have games they're
able to
do projects together we wanted to create
a reality where students aren't just
accountable for their own
gains or their own progress but also for
each other that they're invested in each
other that they are unusually
collaborative
we wanted to explore blurring the lines
between high school and college if kids
are able to learn more be truly curious
be truly engaged why can't they learn
faster than you would normally expect
the middle schoolers can learn high
school concepts
high school students can learn college
concepts and get credit for it so that
by the time they graduate they're
already operating at a junior or senior
level in college and actually getting
credit for it and so
the milestone that we're at is that
we're actually now at a full k-12 school
over 200 students we have our first
graduates this year and you can imagine
in the early days a lot of people
weren't well these are all interesting
ideas sal but will this work and it's a
lab school there's all sorts of stuff
that we're constantly trying but you
know when i look at this year's
graduating cohort i'm incredibly proud
of them
mainly for who they have become as human
beings but some of the traditional
metrics by which we measure students
they're also
crushing it i guess this is the best way
to say it which is which is a which is
really powerful to show that you can
create a learning experience where kids
are intrinsically curious they're
intrinsically want to collaborate with
each other and just want to learn more
but as a byproduct of it not as a goal
of it they're able to do incredibly well
on standardized tests our students are
scoring
on average better on standardized tests
than some of the very top universities
in in the country or in the world
they are getting into some of the top uh
universities in the world
even though they don't have traditional
letter grades because the universities
are seeing that the grades of
mastery-based learning are even more
powerful because it's a higher standard
it's expecting that all students really
mastered the concepts we're deepening
our partnership with foothill college
which is a local college in the area to
get the best of both worlds the high
school experience and the college
experience and so we have some exciting
things that i can't announce just yet
also on the capacity side and so that's
why i'm out here telling folks normally
we can only admit a few folks every year
but this year there might be an
opportunity for more so if you're
interested if you live in the san
francisco bay area in particular within
driving distance to mountain view palo
alto los altos
encourage you to take a look at it and
i'm happy to answer any questions in the
message board below that you might have
about khan lab school
my kids go there i teach there i work
very closely with the faculty and the
administration there
and what's exciting about it for me is
that not just creating a really unique
learning experience for
the students who attend but as a lab
school creating a model that can be
replicated throughout the world so once
again happy to answer any questions that
anyone might have